are relationship prenups
a good idea i say yes
i think that they are a really good idea
i mean
by the time that you get to the point
where you don't want to be with each
other anymore you want it to go
as smoothly as possible i think if you
have a prenup or if you have some sort
of contract
you're already going into the
relationship with an expiration date
you're thinking
i'm gonna break up with you i buy myself
a car
and i put entrance on it with that way
of thinking you're already thinking that
you're gonna have an
accident you're just going down that
route you
signing a will is just you thinking
about death
you can't just think about death like
that
because then you know it's gonna happen
you have a lot of things that you
acquire you know a house
a car accounts and money coming in
it's preparing yourself to an
eventuality that
might happen it's either you're gonna
make it either you're not
prepare yourself some people might say
well you know
it's different because like death is
something that could spontaneously
happen to you yeah and sometimes you can
spontaneously get divorced sometimes
people grow out of love
and they don't want to be with you
anymore that happens even if you want to
all the might you have inside of you
sometimes
some girls just don't want to be with
you that happens some guys don't want to
be with you either
this wasn't a prenup though this was a
contract that he put in front of her 46
pages that says
if we're gonna break up you are out the
door
ladies your biggest your strongest
weapon is your intuition
if somebody's handing you a contract on
day one saying
if it don't work your assets out the
door your ass
needs to be out the door on day one
why people say that when they're the
ones who are not making the money
you know if i'm getting involved with
somebody like common law for example and
then they're entitled to some kind of
financial like
understand my my financial contribution
is not just my partner i also have a
family to take care of
i got people around me who may rely on
me for money like that stuff matters
so when you think you can come in live
with me in a place that i purchase the
place i furnish or whatever it might be
and then think you can take half of that
just after divorce
why if you are someone of character
who's really not in it for the money
right then that's fine so sign the
contract that we all know
because guess what you can say something
but guess what things change after a
while
things can sour very fast when breakups
are about to happen
people can turn resentful for all kinds
of reasons so you may go on being like
i would never but how many times people
said
i would never and they did that
when i hear her i'm just like bruh i
don't bite
listen if i made the money before you
got with me that's mine
that's it that's how i feel about it
that's how i feel about this kind of
financial split stuff
if we came into this relationship way
later when i've already established
myself and my finances are straight and
soaring well what did you contribute to
that wealth and that accumulation
am i crazy to say that but then again
even then when in in the court of law
whenever you
break up they're gonna tell you that
what you brought into the relationship
is not necessarily just money and
they're gonna take an accountability
other things that you bring to the to to
the table and other things that you
bring to the
if you fix things around the house it's
not your money but
you bring that to the table that as well
you can't put a price tag on that
money is easy it's it's a it's a
it's a sign it's a dollar it's a number
it's easy boom that amount of money boom
flip
but there's it's more than that whatever
you contribute to the to the
relationship
is more than just the money you bring
home it's also
everything that you were able to do and
to bring to ease the
relationship cooking taking care of the
kids
a relationship is compromised you know
it's it's a funny thing
i agree if you go into it
with the idea that it's going to end
let me tell you something i don't know a
single person
that has a prenup that ain't had to use
it including yourself steve
has to meet him with divorce three times
as a man i got divorced few times yeah
that's a poor argument
i don't know nobody that had a prenup
that that didn't have to use it
if they had to use it and had the prenup
it proved they were right
it just proved that they were right you
said things when things go well
when things everybody's at ease and when
everybody's in love you don't settle
settling things where people hate each
other that ain't it
that ain't it you settle it when
everybody's in love and everything goes
well
because listen even if you go in with
the best of intentions sometimes they
fail
right steve harvey your evidence of that
you didn't make no prenups
still failed well i think it's always
good to understand that possibilities
there and if that happens
we don't want finances and all that
stuff to be a huge burden within that
dynamic so
stands to reason to me that considering
marriage is such a contract anyways to
begin with
where you're saying this is yours this
is mine this is already established
within the mayor's contract
what's the issue with adding more
stipulations to that to make sure that
every party upon a breakup
is going to see that their side ends
well
sounds was very reasonable i don't know
she said you're preparing for failure
it's like having a plan b yeah it's your
insurance
yes and what's wrong with that yes you
should have plan b's
what do you think you just go into
something like i'm gonna make this work
no matter what
even if it kills me even that is the
dumbest thing i've heard today
if you didn't have a plan b steve you
wouldn't be divorced
multiple times divorce is a plan b
by definition because whenever you marry
yourself
is supposed to be for better for worse
you're supposed to keep on going
but you chose to opt out that's a plan b
so i don't even know what the hell is so
wrong with a plan b
i remember it was chris rock that said
that insurance is not insurance
that nothing is going to happen it's in
case it happened
it should be called in case it happens
you know if
happens you got an insurance hey you
said you don't see what's wrong with
plan b
i bet a lot of women agree
and a lot of tooths oh yeah busting in
them sugar walls raw
i don't see nothing wrong
with a little plan b i don't see
nothing wrong nothing wrong
with a little plan b busting in them
sugar walls
raw what kill me with that b is
ridiculous
if you have a plan b how can you
possibly expect
a to work yeah if exactly if you don't
put your all into
a get the [ __ ] out of here i mean they
tell you
for this for most like facets of life if
you if you're going to work in finance
right if you're going to do investments
you don't put everything in one stock
right you diversify your portfolio
in case your big one doesn't work out
you can still fall back on other things
this kind of like
dumb idea that you only focus on one
thing is crazy like yes
put your energy into the one that's the
most important plus understand
things can go wrong your partner could
die your partner
could decide to leave you you can't
decide these things there's things that
are outside your control
so it's smart in those circumstances
to have a fallback plan just thinking
that because you
think and you work hard that's i'm sorry
i've been a good person so everything
good is gonna happen to me
that's not life you could be the best
bird i know some good good motherf
some good people some great people great
personality everything
they wouldn't hurt a fly happens to them
and pretty hectic stuff too it's not how
that's not how life works that is not
how life works
i put all my effort in this relationship
and this is how you thank me
he's not thanking you or she's not
thanking you it's just things that
happen
and it's not working out and deciding to
split has nothing to do with
you work hard or not you can actually
not put
any any effort in a relationship and it
can still work
old people that really don't like each
other and they're just there and they
can't stain each other
but they're there and there's people
that can put all the effort
to leave you it's outside of your
control sometimes
no real talk real talk if you don't have
a partner that's your fault
you have not because you ask
not did you write it down
you got to write it down it's written in
the scriptures he's simple
he's got to he's three women across from
him and one that there's a reason
yeah but the majority of his audience
what do you think they think
exactly all right i have to go into that
relationship
100 committed not thinking okay if it
doesn't work out
this is what i'm gonna do you know if it
doesn't work out then fine
i'm out of here i don't want anything
i'll go shopping and buy new furniture
right
yeah but that's you that's and that's
what you're saying right now you don't
know how you're going to feel at that
time
you don't know how how scared or where
you're going to be because of financial
situations or
not being able to live the same
lifestyle or whatever it might be
so you can say that now and it sounds
great and you know what
i really believe that in that moment you
believe that
but things change do you think people
when they say tell death do is part
they're saying i'm not committed no
they're 100 percent into it but
happens is it not the case
you think most people who are getting
married like i'm not gonna last in this
no most of them really believe they will
but [ __ ] happens and if it doesn't work
out i hope that you would treat me
accordingly
there are plenty of women who have
busted their butts for their men
they have put in into that relationship
why is it that after five
ten years a relationship doesn't work
you're gonna throw me out of the house
no
i'm keeping the house the car i'm
keeping everything
your ass is leaving the house amen
women like this is exactly why you need
a prenup yup cause she's acting out of
anger not even
out of logic and i guarantee you if you
google her name wrong she's definitely
been divorced
definitely been divorced what's her name
how many
how many spouses she got two
and get this out of here bro you know
what no no no this is the big no no bro
bro
this is the big irony of what she said
peep game she said
what you think you're just gonna throw
me out and then i'm gonna have nothing
you need to let me go the iron is that
most women
are the ones who bring the forces to men
so it's not us saying you gotta leave
you're the one who's leaving
and then you also think that you're
gonna get the house and the car and
everything else
the audacity that's actually to make
yourself sound like the victim
and then also take all the benefits
that's the numbers that's that
that's the numbers it's not taking it
out most men
in all the relationship it's women that
bring mostly women that brings a divorce
that's that's
just a fact
no no no exactly you see you see this
it's not even the equality or what's
right it's everything for women that's
what it is
you know it's crazy it's crazy how women
can get on live television and be this
toxic it's
wild listen my stance on this is very
simple
if we get married and i made the money
before you're not touching that after we
get married we go through the whole
process i'm done to support you
because you've been part of that process
from there on for you know that's how i
feel that's how i'm going to stay
feeling any kind of relationship or
marriage i'm going to get to i'm going
to go with that i'm also going to make
sure i'm going to be with a partner
who's open to that kind of idea because
the people i generally do have some
level
of integrity in that regards and are
fine with that right they're not after
mom so they don't mind signing it's not
a big deal to them
right so i think in terms of showing
commitment i don't think
having a prenup shows that you're not
committed if anything
i think it's an extra form of commitment
because it alleviates any of those
possible stresses that you have
in regards to what may happen in regards
to finances whether you're a man or
woman who's making a lot more
okay it just takes that away because
you're actually because thinking of
after
because not just the relationship the
reason why i say this is because like i
said it before but
i got to think about my mom i got to
think about my brother my sister like
i got people i'm taking care of i can't
have you leave
and then rob them also no it's not going
to work like that
right so i have responsibilities if you
want to be with me in this regards and
you really believe in this then just
sign it we're going to work it out
but to idea like oh if you make this
that's stupid
that's true anybody who gets a divorce
and acts like there's not a plan b like
you lying
that's it most people recognize that
there is a plan b that was a potato tape
yeah no no what you need to do
is put all your eggs in one basket who
says that
who said that ever and i don't even know
how people would think that
and think like that but you know what
the tuple pheromone i guess you know you
need everything to make anything so
it makes no sense at all protect your
neck that's
guys and girls protect your neck as she
said she said
if he gives you a contract you should
leave guys and girls
if you want him or her to sign a
contract and they don't
leave that's what i say yup that's how i
feel
marriage is a contract i don't
understand it is a contract it's like
so you're just adding more clothes more
specificity to what the contract is
that's it
but it's a plan b it's like yo if you
feel so strong just stay with your
partner why you gotta get your signing
any kind of paper
you're not believing it why do you have
to sign the dotted line i'ma drive my
car but i disconnected the airbag
because i got it here just stupid i'm
good i'm done
thumbs [ __ ] i've heard all day wow